nothing makes you happy
other than being useful to others if you
are not happy in life it's because
you're not serving enough I always
wanted to be famous and rich and
successful now I just wanted to serve
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message serve others over
to you will smith also if you want to
know what Will Smith has to say about
confidence and excellence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video
for free to help you build your
confidence the links to join are in the
description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet it takes
such a desperate obsessive focus to to
excel on assert honor on the level that
I want to make movies
[Music]
I think what makes a great emcee is the
same thing that makes a great father it
makes a great husband makes a great
politician makes a great human being and
it is your commitment to your personal
evolution your personal growth for the
purpose of assisting others like you
know I'm working on this record now
called a it's called the mountaintop and
the idea is I've been to the mountaintop
right and it's like I'm gonna do reports
from the summit right I've been to the
top of money I've had all the sex that
I've ever wanted I've had all of the
adulation and and adoration and I've
been to the top of all of those material
world mountains and nothing makes you
happy
other than being useful to others that's
it's the only thing that every will
satisfy that thing is that what you are
is useful if you are not happy in life
it's because you're not serving enough I
believe that humans are good 99.999% of
humans are good there's a tiny little
fraction of a percent of people who
enjoy giving harm and hurting others
because they have some chemical
imbalance but apart from that people are
good and we are connected to each other
your highest purpose in life will come
from helping others but the next
question becomes how how do I do it how
do I find my higher purpose how do I
know what I'm supposed to do how do I
get Direction I'm gonna give you the
three-step process that I call the
purpose planner that will give you the
clarity that you're looking for I break
it down into your who your why and your
how let's start with the who your who
was your one word most important core
value everybody has a core value if
you're a human being you have a core
value that you believe in more than
anything else and when you understand
who you are when you understand your
single most important core value then
you're less likely to be swayed by other
people you're less likely to live
somebody else's version of your life
because they have clarity and you don't
when you do not have clarity you end up
everybody else's clarity you end up
doing their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing it's like you're walking on
quicksand and you're constantly sinking
and you know there's something greater
for you your one word your most
important core value is the rock that
you stand on when the rest of the world
is crumbling around you so for me is
belief my one word is belief that's what
I stand on if you love believe you're
gonna be a huge friend of this channel
because I talk about it in some form in
every video every video should use
believe if you hate believe you're
probably gone by now you hate my channel
and that's okay go go do your thing
somewhere else you need to figure out
your who you need to figure out what
your one word most important core value
is that becomes the lens through which
you see your entire world and attracts
the goodness into your life
step number two as your why why do you
do what you do now I'm a big believer
that your purpose comes from your pain
that whatever your most painful moment
was in life whatever you struggled with
the most growing up in life whatever
moment in life you felt the most
worthless as a human being your highest
purpose your greatest joy and
satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you were in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's gonna be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believed that's my
who my why is I struggle so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life
I was struggling as making a $300 a
month I felt worthless as a human I felt
like I was bringing no value to the
world and that was massively frustrating
I felt alone I didn't know what to do
that's why I love helping entrepreneurs
I loved believing in entrepreneurs why
don't you be any way I could believe in
anybody believe is at the core of Who I
am it's my one word most important core
value but I could be believing in
anybody and I do and I love it but
entrepreneurs hold that special spot for
me and the startup entrepreneurs not the
ones who are already making tons of
money I love them too but I resonates so
much more with the startup entrepreneurs
because I remember what it's like eating
that McDonald's and only being able to
afford french fries instead of an entire
meal so your why your purpose comes from
your pain figure out what that most
painful moment was for you and it's hard
because entrepreneurs we like
looking and being optimistic and looking
forward and being positive but it's in
that pain that your answer actually is
find out what that most painful moment
was your why your highest purpose will
come from helping people who are
currently facing that right now and then
step 3 is the how so how are you gonna
do it there's a lot of ways you can help
people who are in that situation so for
me break it down the who is my one word
it's believe the wise helping
entrepreneurs purpose come from my pain
now how do I help entrepreneurs how do I
believe in entrepreneurs is that there's
a ton of ways that I could be believing
in entrepreneurs so the example I use if
is if you are moving your office and you
need my help to rent a moving truck and
to help you carry your desks and all of
that stuff I love the end result of it I
love that now you have this great office
where you can build a business and have
it flourish and I'll Paulie say yes to
helping you do that so if you're a close
friend but I don't love the process of
moving I don't love the process of
packing up boxes I don't love the
process of setting up cables and wires
and putting together an office I don't
love that process I love the result
because I'm believing in entrepreneurs
but I don't the process and so if you
write down you make a list of all the
things that you do the activities that
you have done that you've enjoyed the
result make a list of 10 to 15 times
you've helped somebody with that same
pain that you had growing up you've
helped them and you enjoyed the end
result and then circle the ones where
you enjoyed the process as well because
when you can enjoy the process and you
enjoy the end result it's a home run
now you've found your higher purpose now
you have clarity now you have a plan
that's the point of the purpose planner
step one you figure out your who your
one word most important core value step
two you figure out your why your purpose
comes in your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because it's so painful
for you and then step three as a how the
process you need to love the process you
figure out those three things you are
set for life now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question
today I want to know what is your
purpose go through that exercise what is
your purpose let me know put it in the
comments below I'm pumped to see what
you have to say
you wanted to be a professional baseball
player Yeah right yeah but then you got
an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big leagues or did
you play minor league for them I did
yeah and I played Division one college
baseball - yeah like every guy like you
and I talked about this last time it's
always our injuries that ended our
careers I probably it probably put me
into a premature place where I was going
anyways I don't really write you aren't
gonna be in the base for I wasn't I
played enough baseball with guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my
limitations yes so like anything in life
things happen for you not to you that
injury happened for me certainly didn't
seem like it at the time but it got me
out of that and into something like what
we're talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like Who am I right
yes lost well like a lot we were just
telling us before we went on yeah we
know our professional athlete friends
were there career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is
when the first one ends and doesn't
happen whether that be a relationship it
could be your marriage events it was a
dream right or a business venture or
sport I went into a pretty good
depression and how old were you at the
time 21 22 and I ended up you know it's
because people always see the after like
the house or whatever houses or whatever
the material things are but I ended up
bad man I ended up to press I ended up
moving back at home with my parents I
was living in the city remember I was
living in this sleep it of the same bed
I grew up in with the same teddy bear
the same posters I was like going back
in time like six years I'm back where I
was totally unemployed and couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after bass pollen you realize
things in your life happened for you
truly especially in hindsight everybody
knows it in hindsight right if you look
back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
later they go that happened for me that
was actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model you could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me
has more integrity than me he's is the
best man I've ever known but when I was
growing up my dad had a drink
and so my dad had gotten sober recently
and he was going to these meetings and
he comes home from one of his meetings
and says there's a guy at my meeting who
can get you a job it's right down the
street in San Dimas you're gonna be
working with kids doesn't pay anything
at six bucks an hour but you're gonna
get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8:00
a.m. ask for Tim so I walk dates I Drive
down there it's a place called McKinley
home for boys little did I know that
would alter my entire life that was the
most significant thing that happened to
me and so I walk in there I said I'm ed
my lad I'm here for the job you like
what job I'm like I don't know just my
dad told me to show up here yeah I need
to ask for Tim they're like we have no
idea who the hell Tim is what's his last
name I said I I don't I don't know it's
they've and they're like so you should
have for a job that you don't know what
it is and you don't know who it is it's
hiring you I'm like here's what I know
he's an alcoholic like oh no that's him
and so they bring me to the guy and he
says uh you're hired let's go like
literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys know where my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically I lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all Ward's of the
court they were all molested by family
roomm inherits were in prison
and so they had no family and so my
whole life changed all the sudden he's
became on this 22 year old guy these
guys become my sons Wow and I did
holidays with them I did birthdays with
them I lived with them literally in a
home or like a little horns or McKinley
is a massive campus full of children
that not in this place from their homes
that live an individual like cottages
like a foster care facility massive
really yeah all hallways it's in San
Dimas here and wow it just altered my
life man because I I'd been an athlete
had a huge ego had that mask I wanted to
compete I wanted to win I wanted
attention I wanted recognition first
time literally in my life it went well I
I love helping people I love making a
difference and my boys were just come
from horrendous situations and so just I
always say this all the time kit and I
have those eyes too you have them I
think sometimes kids who grow up when
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boy
all were different but they had that
same eyes they're just like man love me
believe in ya you know care about me and
I had those eyes cuz I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know it is when you're
an athlete right now everything's about
you you're amazing free dinners free
that's your stud all of a sudden I
wasn't a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me was about these ten boys
and it'll be in ten of them and it just
altered my life man and so after that I
ran into the financial business that I
ended up in but I would have completely
flunked out of that financial business
had I not been with my boys for those
years and I was there for two years two
years yeah man like eight hours a day to
have a thing or sometimes more sometimes
16 18 I I think about I'm not kidding
you I think about my boys and my
experience there two of them are still
very close with me every day there's a
moment where I reflect on that it
altered me completely like what I wanted
to do I always wanted to be famous and
rich and successful and now I just
wanted to serve yeah I wanted to help
little little did I find out I could get
rich and famous and all that other stuff
I thought I wanted through serving
people right and so if you want more
Will Smith check out the top fifty rules
video made on him the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I look at the world through a lens
of comedy my natural reaction is always
no matter when something happens and I
can't even help it it's why is that
funny